welcome back to the playoffs we've got
match ups so good they must be scripted
wake up sheele yes I'm simply buzzing
with excitement in one corner we have
the Ravens I've waited three long years
to get a playoff win and I'll
be my God it's DJ st's music the Phenom
is here nobody believed in me that's my
thing come and get it I'm sorry looks
like the Ravens are making a run I
likely Dory and it has shoud distracted
and the Tex and Cinderella story comes
to an end we also have the chiefs
again Tables Ladders and Chairs Oh My
Sacrifice to the pen Travis may be
spending too much time exploring New
Heights Here Come the DK
Brothers oh and they landed wide right
Chief win one of these teams will win
the very easy crown of AFC Champion
buddy I'm the wrestling guy sorry Pat
I'll I'm like a vampire once you invite
me in I will ruin your life in our
co-main event we have the Niners can you
smell what The Brock is cooking I can
smell what the people around you are
cooking Niners win you know I actually
can recover from that look who's in the
conference Championship I don't want to
hear how hard you've had it they said I
wasn't good enough for Cleveland uh-oh
be DEA the Run Stop's here take me
instead of my precious Jaren lion land
they're having a little too much fun for
my T and the ners will once again
attempt to lose an NFC
[Music]
Championship passenger Josh Allen please
report to the Cancun gate while coach
mcdermit is held by airport
security attention flight 58 to the
Cancun section of grid iron Heights we
are now boarding all veterans all
playoff lock veterans you are now free
to
board